a city facing an extended lockdown so
doctors can get to grips with a flare-up
of kovat 19 in the east of the city the
Army has been called in to run mobile
testing stations there have been more
than 800 positive results in two weeks
almost a third of all the cases reported
in Leicester during the whole epidemic
Saphir came for a test after losing her
sense of taste
she knows several people with the virus
and says it's wise to be cautious
I think safety comes first don't you
agree we need to keep moving but I think
we move slowly with some restrictions
public health England has told the city
authorities that pubs and restaurants
should remain closed for another two
weeks
mixing in doors would be too great a
risk unchecked coronavirus cases can
quickly rise in the national lockdown in
March a delay of just a week may well
have led to several thousand extra
deaths
public health officials are anxious that
the virus doesn't start spreading all
over again but the mayor says the
evidence is unclear on how that would
help if the statistics are right
the virus is already spreading under the
current restrictions while the rest of
England is coming out of lockdown we
would somehow have to remain within it
well that's fine if it is necessary if
they can prove it's necessary of course
we go for it that they have not provided
the evidence but it is necessary or that
it would make any difference if the
extended lockdown is confirmed it would
add to the pain for local businesses at
the market tavern Stuart has so far
poured 7,000 points down the drain give
hope to open this weekend a delay would
eat and his overdraft still further
I'm not a marginal person a lot of
people have welled up a few telephones
missus it's like it ain't nice
just because you sit there go what do we
do now turn otherwise we already down
under than 50 sort of thousand just
alone about another two weeks and it's
another now the cough is super pops oh
go get will be are
so customers around here I think some of
the smaller pubs will go and one local
doctor has warned that people who flee
the city this weekend to celebrate the
end of national lockdown elsewhere could
take the virus with them the more we
disseminate the greater the risk of
producing a wider wider secondary the
more contact people have and the the
greater the population density
particularly indoors the greater the
risk and it's just a numbers game this
won't be the last local flare-up the
national lockdown has been eased before
the virus has been completely eliminated
and the Prime Minister has said a
whack-a-mole strategy would be used
wherever it returns Thomas More Sky News
investor